I got this present actually the reeds mm
Carmichael Merry Christmas and have been
doing it with lots of love information
you want to watch it you know I could
he's a former venture capitalist radio
host YouTube personality and
entrepreneur he sold his first company
in nineteen he said cool world records
he aim to help
1 billion entrepreneurs he's Evan
Carmichael and here are his top 10 rules
for success when I was growing up in
grade 2 grade 3 grade 4 I used to have a
lot of nervous tics some of them are
really embarrassing I used to blink a
lot constantly I used to do this with my
neck and then have to adjust with my
shoulder when I was walking I used to
always have to step on the lines or
completely avoid the lines on the
sidewalk one of the most embarrassing
one was I used to always try to kick my
own butt where I would always have the
I'd have to push my leg up and I
wouldn't be happy until the heel hit my
butt and I have to do that a couple
times before I can move on with the rest
of my day I was also getting into a lot
of fights at my school so seeing this my
parents are really worried and it took
me to go see a child psychologist I
didn't know she was a psychologist my
parents said I was going to go play
games with somebody and we had some
games together and she showed me these
ink blots and told me what do you see in
these pictures and she asked me a bunch
of questions the immediate
recommendation was that I switched
schools right
and so in grade five I transferred to a
new school called Crescent and ended up
staying there from grade five all the
way to graduating high school and the
ticks got better for the most part they
went away completely to this day I still
have a few minor ones where if I'm
thinking or if I'm stressed or if I'm
tired you can see my ears move but other
than that they're gone what it really
made me think about was the importance
of your environment so your environment
is either something that builds you out
that that lifts your spirits that helps
you go chase your dreams or something
that squashes you down that makes you
shrink that makes you accept a lesser
life so think about the people that you
surround yourself with think about the
the TV shows you're watching and the
media that you're consuming and the
place that you go to work
does your environment build you up or
squash you down changing my environment
had a dramatic impact on the quality of
my life and the contribution to my
success as an entrepreneur and changing
yours can have the same impact for you
add more value if you want to be able to
charge what you're worth if you want to
be able to build a successful company
you need to add a ton of value the
amount of money that you make will be
directly related to how much value
you're providing for your customers how
much you're helping them out it's a
pretty simple equation executing it is
difficult but the concept is simple to
understand if you want to make more
money add more value and stop competing
on price when you compete on price alone
it's a loser's game you're not going to
bring on ideal clients you're constantly
going to be struggling to get by you're
not going to be able to hire great
people for your team you have to stop
competing on price stock start adding
more value and you're gonna love your
business more you're going to have more
fun you're going to attract much better
clients you want to work with people who
understand the value provide and not
just cater to the guys who have no
budget who are barely paying you a tiny
profit for what you're doing I believe
everybody has one word that they stand
for and when you figure out what that
one word is your life and your business
will change and it's not just from
marketing it's not just how you promote
yourself but it's who you
surround yourself with the team that you
attract yourself to the products and
services that you launched when I
accompanied and embraced believe as my
one word my business started to take off
my video started doing insanely better
I started attracting the right people
into my team I started launching
products that made sense for people and
people really embraced and so I'm a huge
believer in it and I'm going to give you
a quick method to how to figure out your
one word the first step is you think
about what makes you happy what are the
things that make you come alive what are
the things that you love doing and just
don't even think about what your one
word is yet just think about all the
things that you love doing things you
could do all day long and things that
fill your life with joy write those
things down and this isn't just a
business thing this is you personally
because you want to make this personal
for your business to be successful the
second thing is then look at what
connects them what are all the things
that connect those things that make you
happy
what's the connective tissue and try to
figure out is there one word that can
bring all those things together so think
about what your favorite movie is your
favorite book your favorite your best
friend growing up what you love about
your parents
you know what businesses you've been
attracted to the hobbies that you love
doing what connects them all together
for me it's belief you know I love
Seabiscuit as a movie which is about
this underdog horse in underdog jockey
an underdog trainer
underdog owner and how they all work
together to then win a whole bunch of
races the songs I listen to are always
the uplifting believe kind of positive
ones those are the ones that I gravitate
towards what I love about my parents is
that they always believed in me and told
me that I was a Christian Carmichael I
could do anything that I wanted even if
they didn't give me them the ideas I
have a sort of business they always
believe that whatever I could did I
would be successful at and taught me to
believe in myself
and so it's really important and so all
of those things that I've done across my
life have been about believe and when I
encompass that it allowed me to start
living my life on purpose with direction
instead of just being reacting to it
in every industry is competitive right
every industry is competitive and the
key is you got to be you the key thing
that's going to make you stand out from
everybody else is you I'm trying to
cross the street as I'm saying this
that's a differentiator that's your
market advantage and so you've got to
figure out yes you can model success yes
you can look at people who are big in
the beauty industry and look at how they
rose and those are great examples you
got to take what work for them and then
making your own you've got to find a way
to make this your business and people
will be attracted to your personality
not everybody but a certain group of
people and when I found the best way to
do it is to combine your passions so if
you love beauty that's amazing that's
awesome what else do you love how can
you mix those two things so for example
say you love dancing right you love
dancing that's your passion besides
beauty be the beauty person for dancers
all right the next time doing a photo
shoot the next time we're getting ready
for a performance the next time they're
out there getting into a movie almost
got run over by that guy holy cap
they're going to call you right you're
making videos you've written blog
clothes you're tweeting about makeup and
beauty and dancing and so that's the key
that's how you do it a couple examples
that I've used before in the video one
you know if you like being a
photographer photographer czar super
competitive too but say you love bowling
then you can be the photographer for
bowlers and you're going to be the
default person they go to because they
need people to take pictures and they
want somebody who's passionate bowling
if you love dancing they need people who
can do makeup but they want people who
are passionate all dancing as well and
you can speak both languages that's the
key I got a buddy of mine I've used an
example before named Steve who is a
financial planner I'm a financial
planner
how many financial planners are there
out there tons but he has a passion for
hockey he loves hockey he obsesses over
it he watches it you know as much as he
can watch is the same replay 20 times he
could just watch hockey day-in day-out
he became the financial planner for
hockey players and so when he's talking
to hockey players now he can speak their
language he can talk about hockey you
talk about investments and he's one of
them right a lot of these hockey players
you know that the goal and financial
planning is to target the high net-worth
individuals right the people have
money those people you want to work with
and so he's able to do that by combining
his passions and so make it your own
right find a way to be able to tie
whatever other packages you have into
the beauty business and that's how
you're going to stand out I want to see
more Elissa I want to see your passion I
want to see your personality your
character what you believe in all of
that there's got to be real it's gotta
be you it's got to be human and that
connection to you and everything that
you stand for and believe in it's what's
going to make me want to come to you as
opposed everybody else that's how you
stand down one of the most important
lessons that I've learned in business
and I guess in life is you need to
follow your flow and sometimes there are
external pressures that force you into
following your flow you may get a big
media opportunity you may get a new
partnership you may get a new a big
customer that kind of is a huge big
opportunity for your business and
sometimes following your flow I find
comes from internal reasons internal
pressures maybe you wake up one day and
you really want to go try something out
or you're on a walk or you in a shower
and a new thing comes to your mind and
and I found that by following my flow
and by following that idea it's always
in my best interest one because probably
magic is going to happen if magic is
going to happen it's going to come from
a source of inspiration not just being
you know doing your day to day to day to
day and to I didn't want to live with
regret you know they want to have this
big list of to do is this big list of
ideas that just builds and builds and
builds and this Evernote file that just
keeps growing I never actually take
action on stuff right you have an idea
you want to try something go and take
action on it so yesterday does this
relates to my book yesterday I had a
full day plan
Monday is my busy day I'm recording this
on Tuesdays Monday it's our my my
busiest day of the week and I had a full
day plant in it and then I just it all
exploded on me from an external source
from 50 cent so I made a video and 50
cent saw it and he called it good and he
posted on his Facebook page and he
posted it to his Twitter account he
posted a blog about it he kind of went
crazy promoting this and and as a result
the traffic exploded on my video
comments were coming out of everywhere
people were tweeting me their Senate for
my newsletter they're engaging with the
video it was just insane
and I had a choice of hey I can either
go with this right or I could just do
all the work that I had planned for the
day and I chose to go with it on top of
it it was pretty cool right 50 cent
likes my stuff and is sharing it and I
spent a good amount of time just with my
team just having fun in the moment
looking at the numbers seeing where it
was being shared it's kind of a big
celebration and a win for everybody on
the team so we're all kind of super
pumped and excited and I spent the day
responding to everybody and as a result
got nothing done that I was supposed to
get done for the day
hello believe nation I've talked a lot
about on this channel how when you're
first starting something you're gonna
suck at it right any new skill that you
trying to pick up you're gonna suck
whether it's learning a language picking
up a new sport picking up a new skill
learning the video game trying to
understand marketing or counting
whatever it is you're trying to
understand you will suck at the start
and a story I've told a couple times on
these videos is looking back on my
channel look back on the old videos and
see the progress right 2500 videos later
you can see how I've grown I've gotten
better and I sucked at the start and
hopefully suck a little bit less now but
one thing that time that struck me as I
was watching through my channel was the
end spresso series I started out a
couple months ago and the first one that
I did was of Dame Dash and it was a
selfish project for me because I wanted
something in the morning to kind of get
me excited getting inspired make me
think bigger but when I started it I
didn't have it all planned out and I
think this is something that's really
critical for a lot of you entrepreneurs
is you wanna not over plan and expect to
suck at the start and it's okay because
you're gonna get better and better and
better and better I remember when I had
my first company I really struggled at
the beginning I was making 300 bucks a
month not enough to survive almost gave
up repeatedly and was willing to try
anything I felt like I tried everything
and and nothing was working out I had a
great product and I couldn't understand
why this was so hard because the books I
read and the
sites I visited and the shows I watched
everything seemed to be so easy like
follow these eight steps and you'll be
successful while I follow those eight
steps a million times and I wasn't
successful and one of the big
breakthroughs for me came when I
realized that I wasn't the first guy to
try to do this before my first company
was a software company and I had no
background in software before apart from
using you know a computer but I wasn't a
software designer and the breakthrough
moment came when I did realize that I'm
not the first guy to try to sell
software before and I went and I modeled
some of the largest and most successful
software companies in the world and one
in particular was Microsoft and again I
don't care how Bill Gates makes money
now but how did he go from nothing from
that idea to getting his first customer
what did he do what did he say what were
his actions was what was his mindset who
did he need to connect with and I took
those strategies and applied them to my
business and I finally started to see
results for him was through partnerships
so he made partnerships he had software
he partnered with hardware companies his
big deal came with IBM was a seven
million dollar deal that first one with
IBM that really put the company on the
map but before that he still made
partnerships with other hardware
companies and they sold their their
products as a bundle and so I applied
that strategy and within the first month
I closed my first partnership deal and I
made thirteen and a half thousand
dollars now that may not seem like a lot
of money to you 13k but to me I make the
three hundred bucks a month this was
this was like Eureka oh my god I struck
it rich this is amazing somebody
actually believes in what I'm doing I'm
seeing some positive momentum finally
after all this failure and struggling
and it just kept copying that again and
I applied it again and again and again
and closed more partnerships and more
partitions to continue to grow my
business and eventually got acquired by
someone who is a potential partner they
loved us so much that they wanted to buy
my business and I wish I had discovered
it earlier I wish I discovered the
strategy so much earlier because I
almost shut down like I almost quit my
business and thought maybe I should
listen to my friends and go back and get
a job
and I'm so grateful that I didn't but I
came close many times so having to do
that and so if you're struggling with
your business right now if you don't
have a lot of experience in the field
and it's the first time thing for you
you can't get this thing off the ground
model success find someone who has done
it who's had success in your field look
at the cosmetic lines company see how
they did it
learn from their mistakes so you don't
have to make all the mistakes yourself
and you crunch down your learning curve
so instead of it taking you years and
years and years to achieve success you
can do it a lot faster because you're
modeling things that work that's the
test you know when you are excited by
something when you are passion about
something when you're willing to send an
alarm for something and then wake up
even before the alarm goes off that
tells you that you're on the right path
because too many people trying to plan
it all out right trying to make make it
make sense up here in your head right
it's got to make total logical sense
before I launch and your assumptions are
always going to be wrong and it's never
going to work out like you think it will
you spend so much time planning that you
don't spend any time doing and what you
need to do is follow your passion even
when it sounds crazy you know I don't
know how this business is going to work
out I don't know if it's going to be
with videos I don't know if it's going
to be through and you can see through
tournaments through representing players
I don't know what it's going to be but
what I do know is if I don't do anything
nothing's gonna happen and so by
following my passion and by waking up
early and setting that alarm clock and
getting excited about something we'll
explore we'll try we'll fail we'll make
mistakes and we'll get better and we'll
find our path I need to do the same
thing too but there's something that you
are excited about something that you
want to try then start start even if it
doesn't make any sense because by trying
and making mistakes and figuring it out
you'll land on the perfect business
model to help you explode and grow when
everybody else thought you were crazy
one of the things that I fundamentally
believe is that entrepreneurs make the
world a better place this is we are the
people that drive forward progress we're
the people that create the change and
one of the main reasons why I make these
videos and I'm so
helping entrepreneurs is because you
guys are the ones is going to go out and
create that better future for for my
kids and for my grandkids and so just as
a reminder if you're struggling to I
know there's like the short-term cash
flow crunch and you want to make money
now you're trying to figure out how to
survive and survival is important but
the way to get to becoming a successful
entrepreneur is by impacting people and
some people have a big vision like Walt
Disney and want to create new cities and
other entrepreneurs have a smaller
vision and all you want to do is help
your local community and help your
customers we're buying from you but at
the core of every successful business is
a desire to do good and to make the
world a better place it's what drives me
I wanna I want to have a big impact and
I know I can help people on a small
scale I know I can help you with the
videos and the videos are taking off and
everything I've done is you know it's
growing quickly but I want it to be
bigger right I want it to be
life-changing on a world scale and I
don't always believe that I can do it
because I've never done it before
because it seems like such a big goal
and I'm writing a book right now and
it's I wanted to be an important book I
want to be one of the the top 10 most
read most valuable business books of all
time and that's an easy goal to say
right anybody can say I want to have
this book to be the top 10 book anybody
can say that but who actually believes
that right do I actually believe that I
can write that book because if I don't
I'm not going to write that book and
when I'm talking to people I'm not going
to get them excited and there's a fine
line between confidence and an arrogance
or cockiness but that's the challenge
that I'm going through right now is
believing that I can create this amazing
book and when I'm talking to Jessica
Alba and saying hey you're you know
you're a superhero in the movies but you
should be a superhero in real life as
well you could be a superhero for
entrepreneurs and and help them and be a
model for success for your honest
company I have to do that with a lot of
confidence I have to do that believing
that this
truth thank you so much for watching yo
we made this video because we love you
so much Evan Carmichael and his fans
asked us to we'd also like to know which
of Evans top 10 rules meant the most to
you leave it in the comments we will
join you in the discussion thank you so
much for watching
continue to believe and we'll see you
soon honest Oh what's in the holidays
what's in it
are you serious just can you stand up a
little bit more oh man knowing the red
wine sauce mm-hmm the red wine makes you
okay thank you for watching this video
if you liked the video please give a
thumbs up and enjoy subscribe bye
believe why are you looking at me that's
great okay Oh serpent
baby can you help me
are you too far you tada Justin back
hmm let's go - mm-hmm
two thumbs up high-five mm-hmm ready oh
it's really good
ready oh my god
okay are you gonna break this same just
okay come okay before we go in I've got
to give props to Tim Hortons they
changed their straw on their ice caps
this is red thing now but it's way
stronger so when you mix the drink it's
it's a lot easier and the straw doesn't
Bend so Nina will demonstrate because I
have a hand look see the straw doesn't
Bend props to you Tim Horton's amazing
work these are the kinds of things you
learn on the Evan Carmichael Channel
sayin you listen to me you need to get
out of there was that good send you
listen to me you need to get out of
there
was that close so if you want to tell me
how Americans say out differently than
Canadians and maybe give your own
example please subscribe to the channel
and flee by skip it back
TRUCKING bye so um so I thought what I
want to say Africa okay stop it you're
interrupted you're interfering with my
thought
here we go one-nothing
we's the bottle just like that and you
got thank you
amazing continue to believe I really
appreciate I was waiting for someone to
step up and do it I was waiting I
challenged people in the comments a
couple of times so it's great that it's
an awesome Christmas present feeling the
love I know a lot of work went into that
so uh thank you guys and we'll have an
amazing 2016 together